JAMES GRIME: We love
pi, of course.
Everyone loves pi.
But one of my favorite
pi facts is--
and I think it's fun.
You only need 39 digits of pi
to be able to measure the
circumference of the observable
universe within the
width of one hydrogen atom.
And that's all you need.
Shall we write out
the 39 digits?
So the 39 digits of pi.
It's 3 point--
now, 3 counts as one
of the digits.
So it's now 38 decimal places.
Let's do the 38 decimal
places--
1 4 1 6 5 9 7 9 3 2 7 4 2 0.
-He didn't memorize
that, everyone.
There you go.
Show them what you did,
just in case.
JAMES GRIME: Wolfram Alpha
app, never leave
home without it.
-You're not a pi memorizer,
James.
JAMES GRIME: No, I'm not.
And that's another thing
altogether, people that
memorize this pi figure to a
massive amount of digits.
But people who calculate it
using computers, have
calculated it to, currently,
10 trillion digits of pi.
-Go on then.
Let's do it.
JAMES GRIME: OK.
So that would be all you need.
And that's overkill as it is.
Because that's all you need to
measure the circumference of
the observable universe.
So the observable universe is
the distance that light has
traveled since the big bang.
And if you say travelled in a
big sphere, in a big bubble,
then if you measured the
distance around it, we'd have
the circumference
of the universe.
And we would need pi to work
out that circumference.
And we could be as accurate as
a hydrogen atom, if we used
just 39 digits of pi.
We don't need to use the whole
thing, of course, which goes
on forever.
So in fact, and in practical
day-to-day use in engineering
and real life, you would only
need a handful of digits of pi
to have an accuracy that would
be suitable for anything that
you need to do.
So Wolfram Alpha told me that
the diameter of the universe
was 8.8 times 10 to
the 26 meters.
So that's the diameter of
the observable universe.
If you want to work out the
circumference, then
we times it by pi.
So the circumference would
be pi times the diameter.
What's the difference when I
take away my truncated pi?
What I mean is, what if I took
away my pi with 39 digits--
I've called it pi 39--
and did the same thing
times my d?
So that's the real circumference
of the universe,
take away my approximation.
What's the difference?
If I do that, what I got was
actually around about 2.5
times 10 to the minus
12 meters.
So that's how accurate.
That's the difference between
my approximation
and the real value.
That's how accurate it is.
And a hydrogen atom that Wolfram
Alpha told me had a
diameter of about 2.5 times
10 to minus 11 meters.
So in fact, this is
more accurate.
This is more accurate than
a hydrogen atom.
So why do we calculate pi
to 10 trillion digits?
These days, it's a way to
test our computers, our
supercomputers and
our algorithms.
It's a way to test them to
see how good they are.
That's why computer scientists
are interested in
this sort of thing.
Mathematicians have tried to do
this for thousands of years
out of curiosity.
So it started with Archimedes.
He tried to get an accurate
idea of pi about 250 BC.
He didn't have decimals
in those days.
He had to use fractions.
But he tried to work it out.
Then in the 17th century,
there was a Dutch
mathematician called-- now I'll
probably Anglicize his
Dutch name.
And I apologize.
He was called Ludolph
van Ceulen.
And his life's work was working
out the digits of pi.
And by the end of his life,
he had worked out
35 digits of pi.
And they're on his tombstone,
which is kind of cool.
It's kind of neat.
We skip on to the
19th century.
There was a guy who had about
707 digits of pi.
This was the authoritative
example of pi for over 100
years, until 1945.
And they found a mistake.
I know, shock.
They found a mistake.
And the last 180 digits
were wrong.
Because somewhere along in his
calculations, somewhere around
the 500th decimal point,
he had made a mistake.
And from that point on,
everything else was wrong.
What a disaster.
Fortunately, we were able to use
computers by this point.
So in 1949, ENIAC, the American
computer, was able to
calculate pi to 2000 digits.
So suddenly, it just exploded
after that.
Once we've got computers,
it just exploded.
We had more and more
digits of pi.
And now, we've got 10 trillion